so the Democrats a radical left
Democrats that do-nothing democrats
decided when i'm going tonight oh this
was set up a year ago that when I'm
going to NATO that was the exact time
this is one of the most important
journeys that we make as president and
for them to be doing this and saying
this and putting an impeachment on the
table which is all just got off with if
you notice there was breaking news today
the Ukrainian president came out as this
very strongly the president Trump did
absolutely nothing wrong
that should be case over but he just
came out a little while ago and he said
president jump did absolutely nothing
wrong and that should end everything but
it will never end it because they want
to do what they want to do are they
getting killed in their own district I
think it's going to be a tremendous boon
for the Republicans Republicans have
never ever been so committed as they are
right now and so United so it's really a
great thing in some ways but in other
ways it's a disgrace
I love going to have to understand it
was great meeting with as you know we
had the burger baited with a lot of
people what he got he you know that
right
and he was terrific he was great meeting
with him but my trips Afghanistan was
very successful that we're going to
London and it'll be NATO and we're
meeting with a lot of countries and
they're good have to do a little 4:30
sharing
the Chinese are always negotiated I'm
very happy where we are and frankly
I could be other places that I can do
all by myself in these and happier and
you understand what that means
Chinese want to make a deal we'll see
what happens
really
what's happened to that currency they
devalued their currency very
substantially by 10% Argentina all
and I gave them a big break on tariffs
but they'll take you that breakup is
very unfair to our manufactures and very
unfair to our farmers our steel
companies will be very happy and our
farmers will be very happy
what if your lawyer to represent your
point
the whole thing is a hoax
everybody knows it all you have to do is
look at the words of these brilliant
residents that he just issued and you
know it's a hope it's an absolute
disgrace what they do to our country